this video is brought to you by omaze
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
electric cars are positioned for a
revolution but in pursuit of more range
more performance and faster charging
times there's still
room for improvement the answer could
lie in a technology called solid-state
batteries
even though solid-state batteries have
been studied since the 1950s
and meaningfully built since 2011 by the
bola company the technology
still hasn't broken through on a large
scale yet
as you'll soon see there's a lot of good
reasons for solar state batteries to
take over
such as much faster charging times a
higher energy density
but there's also some challenges in
today's episode
you'll see how toyota may have finally
cracked the code
we'll take a look at what the automaker
plans to do and the pros and cons of the
battery technology
you are watching cold fusion tv
toyota has been researching solid state
batteries since 2012
and in 2020 they announced a prototype
car using the technology that will be
revealed this year
if you've seen my toyota documentary
you'd know that they've been built on a
history of innovation throughout the
20th century
in fact toyota has over a thousand
patents
involving solid-state batteries when you
combine this with a 19.2
billion dollar investment from the
japanese government that includes funds
for domestic work on solid-state
batteries
a breakthrough was bound to happen so
firstly
how does the technology work simply put
solid-state batteries use a solid
electrolyte as opposed to a liquid or
polymer gel
found in current lithium-ion batteries
they function broadly like regular
batteries
using cathodes and anodes separated by
an electrolyte that allows charged ions
to pass through it
while discharging power oxidation occurs
at the anode to create compounds with
free-flowing electrons
these electrons deliver electrical
energy the compounds at the cathode gain
electrons and thus store power
when the battery is charged the process
is reversed
solid-state batteries offer a greater
energy density
anywhere from two to eight times a
regular battery all while having the
same weight
as well as lower risks of fire
on the point of fire less safety
measures are needed
so more space can be dedicated to
packing in more power
the heat generated inside a solid state
battery is 70 to 80 percent less than a
regular battery
the technology also avoids toxic
materials found in current batteries
faster charging longer cycle life and
higher voltages
are all additional advantages
[Music]
so what do we know about this new
battery from toyota
toyota claims that its newly developed
battery can enable a maximum ev range of
500 kilometers
and a charging time from zero to a
hundred percent of just
10 minutes and they say this is quote
all with minimal safety concerns end
quote
the company adds that the new batteries
provide double the range of what would
have been possible with a traditional
lithium-ion battery with no compromising
on interior space
the reports are also saying that this
solid-state battery car
will be an suv built on the existing
e-tng a platform
the new suv is expected to debut in 2021
but only in prototype form
the full production version should be
revealed in about 2023 or 2024
and this isn't just some pie in the sky
thing on the manufacturing front
the ball is already rolling japanese
auto material makers
are rushing to set up the infrastructure
to supply automakers
mitsui mining will start up a pilot
facility that will make solid
electrolytes for the batteries
the production site will be able to
produce dozens of tons of solid
electrolytes annually
starting next year enough to fulfill
orders for prototypes
so i know what you're thinking this all
sounds too good to be true
doesn't it if solid state batteries are
so good
why aren't we seeing them everywhere so
before we get ahead of ourselves
let's take a look at some problems with
the technology
[Music]
number one the cost traditionally
solid state batteries are very expensive
to produce
in 2012 one single 20 amp hour battery
cost 100 000 us dollars to produce
to give you an idea an electric car
would need a thousand of these expensive
batteries to run
but for now it seems that toyota and
other players have overcome the cost
hurdle if they're aiming for a
production solid state car
in the next five years number two
temperature performance solid state
batteries are known to have questionable
performance in cold temperatures
so their long-term durability has a
question mark we'll have to see if
toyota has gotten around this issue
i have little doubt that they would have
otherwise they would be facing lawsuits
in the future i'd imagine
number three damage from dendrite
formation
solid state batteries traditionally have
a problem when charging and discharging
and this problem is the formation of
dendrites these are
needle-like structures that form on the
anode as it charges
as time goes on these structures grow
and damage the battery
however solutions to this problem have
been worked out by researchers since
as it stands other automotive
manufacturers are looking to use
solid-state batteries
nissan and volkswagen are two such
companies the latter has its site set on
commencing battery production as early
as 2025
in partnership with a company called
quantum scape
in 2021 the quantum scape team remarks
that they've resolved all of the core
challenges that have plagued solid-state
batteries in the past
such as incredibly short lifetimes and a
slow charging rate
the thing that sets them apart and the
interesting thing is they actually have
the hard data to prove it
according to their testing their cell
can charge from 0 to 80
capacity in 15 minutes and retains more
than 80
of its capacity after 800 charging
cycles it's non-combustible
and has a volumetric density of more
than a thousand watts per liter
which is nearly double the energy
density of the best lithium ion cells
the key for them was a flexible ceramic
separator that sits between the cathode
and the anode
it's also worth noting that this company
just didn't come from nowhere
the quantum scape team took 10 years and
300 million dollars of r d
before coming across this discovery uh
what exactly have you
achieved or announced and with this
breakthrough on the solid state battery
front
and when will it start to get produced
the solid-state battery
has been something that's been pursued
for probably 45 years since the mid-70s
but no one has been able to make a
solid-state electrolyte which is the
material through which lithium-ions move
that's what we have finally achieved and
the results that we showed last week
demonstrated that we could actually run
these batteries under
real world operating conditions the
fundamental technology itself though
has been run by our automotive customers
in their labs so we know the
technology works i'd say this is very
encouraging
but as always we should take it with a
grain of salt
and it's not just the automobile
industry that sees the potential of
solid-state batteries
researchers at mit have created a phone
battery that can last three days
they've also solved a lot of the common
problems that's associated with the new
battery technology
most of you have also probably heard
about samsung's solid-state battery
efforts their experimental battery
achieved 900 watt hours per liter
and over a thousand charge cycles this
equates to a car with about 500 miles of
range
so to me it seems that after decades of
work and no progress
solid state battery tech will finally
get its stay in the next five years
in addition to all of this regular
liquid lithium-ion batteries have fallen
by 88
in the past decade basically another
positive driving force for the electric
revolution
before we wrap up the video i just want
to give a quick shout out to today's
sponsor
omaze if you've ever wanted to donate
money to a good cause
but also have a chance to win something
big today
i'm partnering with omaze to make that
happen omaze is offering you the chance
to win a house in florida or one million
dollars in cash
one winner will also take home a brand
new tesla model 3
with taxes and shipping included it's
the dual motor model
with 300 miles or 480 kilometers in
range
when you enter the fund received from
the giveaway will help
children's miracle network hospitals
they're building a state-of-the-art
epilepsy monitoring unit
it's going to provide life-changing care
for kids of all ages
and this is for a broad range of
neurological disorders including
epilepsy
to enter simply go to the link below
so toyota has yet to specify exactly
when we'll be seeing the new battery
but it's scheduled for this year i think
it would be so interesting to see if
they've actually achieved what's been
promised for the past 60 years
and i'll definitely be keeping an eye
out for it this comes during the news
that norway has become the first country
to sell more electric cars than petrol
cars
at 54 in 2020 electric cars beat out
petrol
diesel and hybrid engines combined it's
a specific example
but it shows that electric cars are on
the move with solid state batteries
seeming on the horizon
it might be the final piece of the
puzzle to push electric cars
truly mainstream if you want to see how
toyota started and learn about their
size
i've done a documentary on it it's one
of the most popular videos on this
channel so be sure to check it out
so that just about wraps up the end of
the video i want to thank you guys for
watching
if you did like this video and want to
see anything on technology
business or history be sure to subscribe
to cold fusion
next time we'll be continuing our story
on intel
my name is tagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon
for the next video cheers guys have a
good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]
you